she said the same things that I've heard
over and over again Hanabi asks
producers to step in over the drama
surrounding Luke P as she and her men
headed to Scotland the home of the Loch
Ness monster it's going to be a great
change of pace although it was cold the
24 year old pageant princess heated
things up with several of the guys
overseas including a front runner Jed
[Music]
this is just nothing
I can tell you and things got heavy
between Hannah and the seasons villain
Luke P things erupted after Hannah tried
to get to the bottom of his feud with
Luke s who left the show early on in the
episode and he warned her about Luke P I
would just urge you to keep your eyes
open for you know I think you know what
I'm talking about it's really important
that I continue to tap into the strong
woman that I am and make decisions for
myself later Hanna tried to talk things
out with Luke on their one-on-one but
when he wasn't giving her what she
wanted she asked producers to intervene
can somebody talk to him about what it
means when I say how do you feel you
have to talk I can't give you this race
so no rose for Luke P but judging by the
promo for next week's episode we haven't
seen the last of him
it's my fault I know that she forgives
me
et recently spoke with the blonde beauty
at CMA fest 2019 where she was shocked
to see how Luke P interacted with the
guys when she wasn't around it's really
hard sometimes to watch back the show
because I mean it's especially in that
it's since you know there are certain
things that I don't get to see and I'm
not previewed to see I mean I only get
what the conversation that I have with
each of the guys and so it is sometimes
difficult to be like oh so that's
actually what happened I mean it was a
little upsetting but you know that is
something that I knew that I just wanted
to be able to really just figure
everything out for myself and you'll see
me do that I take the information that
I'm giving and and I just trust
throughout the process that I will be
able to make my own decisions with the
information I'm getting in my
discernment in my own time and you'll
just have to keep watching and see how I
do that
[Music]